let's have a look at this together and
you've made some progress which is great
what I'm going to do is I'll see if
you're on the right track and you can
compare with me if you're like okay I
think I know what's going on but in
addition to I've got the right answer
and I know what it looks like as well
because the ultimate thing we're going
to do here is graph which I should write
down and you should too
the ultimate thing is in extension to
complex numbers I think it's really easy
just to kind of do just go through the
process you're like you're really good
at algebra now which is going to be a
major component of how we solve this but
because you're so good at algebra you
can often sort of fall in the trap of
not knowing why you're doing what you're
doing and not knowing like what's what's
this result at the end mean in relation
to this so I'm not just gonna show you
the answer I also want to tease out some
of why it is what it is okay now very
broadly speaking there are two kinds of
graphs that you'll encounter within
complex numbers on the Argand diagram on
the our game plane the two kinds are
number one you know those ones where you
see something like say AG z is greater
than pi on two and you know sorry
yeah great and pound - and I put my
inequality other way let's make it less
than and between PI over four right so
you've got some complex number and when
you measure its primary argument right
from our positive real axis it's gonna
be between time for amplitude so you
know there's that sector did you end up
getting right I could say you know how
about mod Z is just going to be less
than three okay so we're going to get
what shape out of that outer circle
because we're just looking for the
distance from the origin and make sure
it's less than whatever is set right so
there's a whole bunch that you have to
think of them in terms of just the
complex numbers but then there's those
other kinds which essentially become a
Cartesian graph right we're going to
resolve these guys because we're like I
don't I don't know what happens when you
geometrically square the conjugate of a
number and subtract that from like I
don't even know what that looks like in
a ready way I need to actually dig into
the algebraic weeds and then try to find
my way through there and get this in all
X's and Y's okay so that's just to say
okay we're cleaning clearly leaning
towards this family of functions and so
what are we going to do here you
actually need to state something right
out the gate before you can even begin
you
to introduce some variables right what
would you like to introduce I'm gonna
start with let Z equal X plus iy we
don't fix right this is that Cartesian
leaning I mean you could have said a
plus IB but then you're gonna have an a
axis and a B axis which just don't fit
our brain is nice and neatly so I'm
gonna introduce that and that means that
I can now express everything that I have
here in terms of my X's and my y's and I
wonder how you went with this I'm gonna
get my I'm actually gonna go straight to
squaring it cuz I think you know this
well enough right if I've got my X plus
iy in here and then I square I'm gonna
get my x squared piece I'm gonna get my
middle piece and then when I do my iy
squared or iy squared what am I going to
get when I resolve that minus y squared
very good okay so there's my expansion
of just that number and that's something
which we want to become reasonably
comfortable with doing then we're going
to subtract okay now because this is the
conjugate right we're doing all the same
things so is this x squared gonna be any
different
nope same deal all right this guy how
will this be different just a minus
because I'm gonna have minus iy I'm
multiplying in there
- what about this piece is this gonna be
pass thank think let's just if whenever
you like oh now I'm not sure then you go
back I mean you don't want to waste time
doing extra algebraic expansions you
don't need to but if you do need to then
do it right if I've got Z bar X minus iy
let's do the squaring now right this
whole thing gets squared so I had my X
square I had my minus 2xy which you are
happy with before if you had a minus B
all squared then this last piece right
is going to be still plus I Y squared
because the - also gets squared that
okay this - that we had here came from
the eyes and that hasn't gone anywhere
so I'm still going to write wrong color
- y squared is that okay and you can see
clearly a whole bunch of things are
going to collapse here that's why we
like conjugates because they fit so
nicely together finish my modulus sign
there and it's going to be greater than
or equal to 16
or now because we did it in this way you
can see the bits that are gonna be nice
and you're gonna fall out tell me what's
going to cancel first thing great
they're gone by the way I'm doing this
very deliberately when you've got a lot
of terms to cancel either by subtraction
or by like fractions and that kind of
thing I encourage you to do it like this
you know if you've only got one other
color with you rather than like actually
crossing out the thing we look at you're
working right and it becomes harder to
read even if we know what you're doing
if you just like screw blue out things
on top of it so this does the same
purpose you can still see those are
aligned what else cancels yeah so I've
got a minus y-square there and a minus y
squared and it's exactly how I'll write
it so that I can see the difference okay
so that's really good that leaves me
with okay what if I got here for I X Y
are you okay with that
yep yes yeah now I'm gonna come to that
I in a second we'll deal with him
briefly I'm gonna deal with my real
numbers here because they're nice and
easy and they're positive as well so I'm
gonna divide through by four which gives
me this and now what should I pause okay
because sitting you very close to this
but there's a subtle difference and I
wonder if you've worked it out yet
because you're working is so close but
not quite
we need to think about this quite
carefully okay if I gave you something
like say the absolute value of five a if
we were just you know two unit students
and we were living in real number land
we could really comfortably say this is
just five times the x value but in fact
that's kind of what we did here when we
divided through by four we factorize out
before we divide it through we just did
all the one hit okay
but you have to be super careful dealing
with complex numbers you've already
learned hopefully you know this rule
this rule here that we've been using for
ages with just normal real numbers are
you guys familiar with what happens to
this in complex number land have you
encountered this before if you haven't
Tommy no because they're not explain it
but if you have I don't a boy you so is
there something you've met before I mean
you said you know sir you got it for me
how about you guys DEP has been
addressing class okay so let me just
mention this right this is something we
know what to do with if for example I
gave you the square root of
60 which is not squared right but we can
see square numbers in there so you guys
should reflexively say the biggest
square that I can pull out of this is I
think it's gonna be four yeah so you'd
say okay that's the square root of four
times the square root of 15 which gives
you this right and that's like a big
part of all we want you to do when we
introduce search for the first time is
do a whole bunch of simplifying just
like this okay
this is fine this is fine in real
numbers okay everything looks happy
there but it sends you the second you
enter the complex said you run into
troubles for example what happens if
both a and B are just negative one okay
now if we're in complex number land
right we have a name for negative for
the square root of negative one we
called it it is the basic building block
right so you should be able to tell me
we just did I squared over there the
answer of course is notice one okay but
if I use this rule which you've relied
on very faithfully for many years now
and see what happens if I try and draw
inequality here so it's really bad
multiplication zone that's better have
you noticed what happens right this is
my square root of a be negative one
times negative one of course is just one
you like what oh what happened and the
answer is this rule actually only works
when a and B are both strictly positive
if we are willing to deal with complex
numbers suddenly things break down by
the way just for extra bonus points I
think it's probably not until you
haven't done inverse functions there's a
topic you have you know not yet
you will encounter that next year so
that you can do inverse trig and
what-have-you and they're part of the
reason why this is a problem is because
the square root function right it's an
inverse function with a restricted
domain we restrict it to the positives a
quick question for you why do we
restrict it to the positives why don't
we let like give me a word definition of
verbal definition of the square root of
something is how would you define that
yep yeah you say that again see if I got
that right and to see if you guys agree
the square root of something is the
number that if you multiply it by itself
you'll get your number right doesn't
that fit this isn't negative 1 by that
definition one of the square roots of
one because if you multiply this by
itself sure enough you get there right
but instead we restrict the domain
because when was the first time we
really needed square roots like to
actually use it in problems with a
particular kind of shape these guys
right
you let Pythagoras's theorem and then
all of a sudden you're like oh I've got
to find out you know to find out the
hypotenuse right but this is our length
in lengths then positive things are the
only thing that makes sense does that
make sense but it causes a problem in
here you don't have triangles with like
oh let's let's make that imaginary unit
right so that's why there is a
restriction it solves a problem for us
but it creates other ones you have to be
careful with